[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
dernier numéro de la saison numéro
spécial sur les idées sorties pour les
vacances et profiter pleinement de votre
été dans les yvelines
tout de suite le sommaire
l'ile-de-france est le théâtre à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
un mois de spectacles d'ateliers
d'initiation en compagnie des tréteaux
de france david koenig et chef de projet
de cet événement nous a parlé du
programme jusqu'au 14 août
redécouvrez le parc zoologique de thoiry
pendant les vacances plusieurs
nouveautés installé cette année un trek
au coeur de la faune australienne ça
fait rire parc pour voir la savane du
sommet des arbres visite de ses
attractions
enfin les communes propose de nombreuses
animations tout l'été montigny le
bretonneux trappe ou maurepas et pour la
première fois plaisir a mis en place ces
estivales mélanie poquet a testé pour
nous quelques activités pour les
vacances les différents châteaux du
département se met aux couleurs
estivales à breteuil jusqu'au 2
septembre de nombreuses visites guidées
ont lieu tous les jours l'occasion de
redécouvrir les différentes scénographie
des contes de perrault et notamment la
nouveauté 2018 peau d'âne à rambouillet
le château prend ses horaires d'été
jusqu'au 30 septembre il est ouvert tous
les jours sauf le mardi jusqu'à 18
heures à ne pas manquer la visite de
l'appartement de l'empereur réouvert
cette année enfin à versailles des
spectacles durant toutes les vacances
la sérénade royal dans la galerie des
glaces et les grandes eaux nocturnes
reprennent du service jusqu'au 15
septembre un voyage féerique au coeur du
domaine royal les yvelines font leur
cinéma revient pour une sixième édition
le festival se déroule du 18 août
jusqu'au 1er septembre avec une
trentaine de séances dans tout le
département
comédie familiale film pour les plus
jeunes mais aussi pour les plus grands
tous les habitants sont invités à
participer aux projections gratuites en
plein air organisées dans les communes à
elancourt il y aura du suspense avec
jurassic world dans la cour de l'école
willy brandt l'avant dernier épisode de
la célèbre saga jurassic park qui sera
diffusée le 28 août
ces animaux méritent ils d'être protégés
comme les autres espèces
vous faut-il les laisser mourir
ces créatures étaient là bien avant nous
si on n'y prend pas garde
ils seront encore là bien après
koné
[Musique]
l'ile-de-france est le théâtre dans le
quatre îles de loisirs de la région pour
cette deuxième édition le centre
dramatique national débarque à saint
quentin en yvelines pour la première
fois nous avons parlé de la
programmation avec notre invité
mais annie poker aux moyens techniques
c'est ici à lille le loisir de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que le centre
dramatique national les tréteaux de
france montra son chapiteau pour un mois
de théâtre avec nous david koenig chef
de projet de cet événement est directeur
administratif de la compagnie bonjour
bonjour alors du 14 juillet au 14 août
c'est une programmation entièrement
gratuite il y aura des spectacles au
mois d'août et dès le mois de juillet le
public est invité à devenir acteur vous
proposer des initiations au théâtre avec
les comédiens des tréteaux de france
oui nous pensons que le théâtre se fait
par la pratique s'apprécie par la
pratique donc on lance d'abord une série
d'ateliers tout le mois de juillet tous
les week-ends du mois de juillet
pour initier faire goûter ça coûte et
par la pratique le terrain alors comment
ça va se dérouler à différents ateliers
différents jeux il ya plusieurs jeux
plusieurs ateliers durant tout le mois
de juillet il y aura vraiment
l'initiation de base des ateliers assez
court 1h30
c'est un peu court pour un atelier
théâtre mais voilà il faut faire goûter
d'abord après on pendant le mois d'août
qui aura des ateliers plus approfondie
sur des sujets plus particulier sur le
débat sur la lecture à voix haute sur
les choses comme ça et vous disiez c'est
des initiations que c'est vraiment
accessible pour le plus grand nombre
même les plus jeunes un peuple comment
on peut venir
tout le monde peut venir tout le monde
peut venir en même temps c'est on ne
spécifie pas on peut mélanger peut venir
nos acteurs sont formés pour initier
toutes sortes de publics dans toutes
sortes de conditions après ils
s'adaptent ils travailleront sur les
relations parents-enfants s'il ya des
parents et les enfants ils travailleront
avec des petits 6 1 est petit et ainsi
de suite et on lit des dents de faire
venir le jeu c'est à dire le fait que le
théâtre advienne et si une chanson
justement même pour des personnes qui
connaissent pas du tout le théâtre de
commencer par ses premiers pas avec des
acteurs professionnels
c'est l'occasion de goûter un genou on
tient beaucoup à ce que la pratique se
fasse que la pratique permettent de
connaître il ya beaucoup d'idées reçues
sur le terrain près donc on essaie de
casser ça présentez-nous un petit peu
justement les tréteaux de france puisque
ces initiations se dérouleront avec les
comédiens alors vous êtes une troupe
itinérante
l'idée c'est d'aller vraiment à la
rencontre du public dans des lieux où va
pas le théâtre habituellement alors
c'est c'est à la fois une histoire et
c'est très moderne c'est les tréteaux de
france existe depuis cinquante neuf mais
déjà avec un chapiteau et des cabines
des roulottes et on allait partout en
france lyon mais je sais pas moi
partout en france à mener le théâtre est
un théâtre populaire de haute qualité
c'est internet qui était accessible à
tout le monde il fallait pas dire que
untel ou unetelle ne pouvait pas aller
ne pouvait pas venir au théâtre
et puis depuis 2011 l'arrivée de robin
renucci à la tête des tréteaux s'est
adjoint a ajouté une dimension plus
pédagogique de sensibilisation au
théâtre et on fait ça partout en france
enfin là on revient dans une création à
saint laurent du maroni en guyane
on vient du gard on vient de des
ardennes on vient de voix là et ici à 50
ans 50 et en yvelines alors aux marines
ou de chien vous l'avez évoqué c'est un
comédien acteur également notamment vu
la télévision dans un village français
il a pris la tête
c'est maintenant le directeur
effectivement de des tréteaux de france
oui il est c'est un comédien qui a une
très longue histoire de jeu qui a été
formé à l'école charles dullin c'est
important parce que ça te c'est ça qui
donne aussi son intérêt pour jouer
devant tous les publics
cela vient beaucoup de lins et puis il
est devenu metteur en scène aux tréteaux
de france
oui justement alors metteur en scène
double casquette comédien et metteur en
scène et c'est lui qui met qui met en
scène le spectacle la guerre bessalah
membres qui est présenté à lille de
loisir de se jouer trois fois ici c'est
un récit actuelle qui date d'avant
guerre
karel capek un auteur de science-fiction
très près de questions sociales qui se
pose juste avant guerre
imagine une fable ou 1
un pêcheur de perles une espèce de
pirates des îles de bornéo et c'est
découvre un genre de peuples manimal
mais qui marche sur deux pattes qui vit
dans l'eau et qui vit pas dans l'eau et
et qui mange des huîtres et qui a des
ennemis qui sont les requins et qui est
avide de trouver des alliés qui sont les
hommes parce qu'il leur fournisse des
explosifs pour fabriquer leurs habitats
et des couteaux pour battre les requins
l'espace vital des salamandres bien se
fait au détriment de la terre ferme
donc il ya un ultimatum un moment des
salamandres face aux humains en disant
nous avons besoin de la terre et donc
n'est la guerre et c'est vraiment très
actuelle effectivement ça a été écrit il
ya un petit moment on retrouve sa
hormones anticipations c'est un roman
d'anticipation c'est aussi une fable un
peu écologique parce que ça montre
comment l'avidité de l'homme
créer la destruction de sa propre
richesse
en fait c'est par souci du lucre du
profit que la terre est détruite
alors on n'a pas le temps de dévoiler un
lancement de la programmation à faire un
dernier mot sur un dernier rendez-vous
alors plus intimiste là c'est la boîte
et donc c'est avec un spectacle avec un
spectateur la boîte c'est vraiment
intimiste c'est pour un spectateur un
acteur et un spectateur chacun dans une
partie de la boîte séparées par un
grillage
c'est une boîte pas du tout oppressante
une boîte lumineuse on la lumière de
l'extérieur passe à l'intérieur
c'est une boîte blanche assez beau
s'appelle objets et chaque spectateur
reçoit une parole 20 bonjour puis un
texte poétique de 45 secondes à deux
minutes et puis un au revoir et ça
s'arrête là et c'est un cadeau il ya un
cadeau qui est donné à chaque spectateur
le plus souvent le spectateur sort un
peu intimidé après le tout qu'y être
intimidés avant et puis il garde ça pour
lui pendant un temps et puis il revient
faire la queue pour recevoir un autre
texte
sincèrement côté un petit peu
confidences inquiets joue c'est un côté
confidences
en même temps on aborde des sujets tout
à fait est vaste puisque les thèmes
choisis des des poèmes sont l'exil est à
tu et à toi ça les poèmes qui tutoie
donc quelque chose de très adressé au
jeune public aussi il ya des textes pour
les très jeunes enfants s'il le faut
c'est pour tout le monde pour tous merci
encore david cioni d'avoir été avec nous
alors on le rappelle de nombreux
spectacles sont à découvrir jusqu'au 14
août
rendez vous sur le site internet des
tréteaux de france pour retrouver
l'ensemble de la programmation et vous
pouvez aller à la rencontre des
comédiens sous le chapiteau de la
compagnie installée à lille et loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines
partez en australie où jouent aux singes
dans les yvelines cette année le parc
zoologique de thoiry qui fête ses 50 ans
inauguré quelques nouveautés pourquoi ne
pas profiter des vacances pour les
découvrir un reportage réalisé avec toki
nirhy lanto pouvoir observer les animaux
plus près en totale immersion c'était
l'objectif du parc de thoiry lors de sa
création en 1968
cinquante ans plus tard le zoo a
inauguré sa nouvelle animation un trek
australiens avec une volière 80 oiseaux
de six espèces différentes dont qui on a
des oiseaux de type perroquet avec des
cacatoès et des perroquets et on a
d'autres oiseaux aussi qui vont être les
vannes au soldat par exemple où les
colons mintues revers parmi les moins
farouches les lots ricker quand ciel
pendant l'été les visiteurs peuvent les
nourrir une première pour jade et ses
grands-parents usage de ces magnifiques
et c'est plein de couleurs déjà vers les
os de très chiant impressionnant déjà on
est venus en voyage de noces il ya 40
ans donc là on regarde les petits
enfants pour les plus téméraires
direction la savane et surtout les airs
le parc installé 1500 mètres carrés de
filair rebondissant dans les arbres de
quoi prendre un peu de hauteur et voir
les animaux sous un autre angle de sa
ferrière parc c'est hyper sympa on voit
bien les animaux du bout là on a plus
beaucoup moins l'impression qu'ils sont
enfermés on est on les voit carrément
liberté c'est encore mieux dans la
voiture je trouve et surtout pour les
enfants c'est un vrai bonheur
sont trop contents ils attendaient que
ça c'est trop bien là à ce moment il ya
fin d'aménagement et tout ça est du coup
c'est super en tout les trucs et
danseuses aux fins il ya toujours des
trucs sur les pleins de trucs pour les
enfants à une baby-sitter
on découvre aussi de nouveaux amis
animaux qu'on n'a jamais vus pendant
l'été le zoo safari de thoiry accueille
les visiteurs de 10 heures à 18 heures
tous les jours
chaque année 400 mille personnes
découvrent le parc pour patienter avant
le départ en vacances ou pour profiter
même en restant dans les yvelines de
nombreuses communes ont concocté un
programme 100% estivale
c'est même le nom de ce rendez-vous à
plaisir une première pour la ville on
retrouve manip hockey au château c'est
même la vie de château ici camille
depuis le 9 juillet ce sont les
estivales tous les jours du lundi au
vendredi de 13h30 à 19h sport et détente
sont au rendez vous ok joue la corde
avec mon chemise et aimant jean jé pas
forcément la bonne tenue alors le temps
de me changer
écoutez madame le maire vous vous rendez
compte qu'il y en a pour tous les goûts
à la fois pour les tout-petits petit
dans la zone très sécurisé des communs
du château avec des éléments comptables
et puis vous avez également ici pour un
peu plus grand voire les adultes les
ados et puis aussi des personnes on va
dire les seniors qui viennent pour un
peu de calme
bonjour alors qu'est ce que la slackline
salle atelier équilibre où on s'amuse à
faire les funambules en fait j'ai vu des
enfants très doué il peut essayer avec
plaisir
alors tu vas prendre un bâton dans
chaque main tu vas venir poser ton pieds
bien à plat sur la capi très fort cet
âge en super gt de rester droite
[Musique]
j'imagine qu'au bout d'un moment on peut
vite lâché les bâtons oui oui oui c'est
ça après on fait lâcher un bâton après
on fait lâcher l'autre on reste toujours
un petit peu à côté puis ceux qui sont
vraiment à l'aise et on les laisse faire
tout seul après ici on est dans le monde
des tout petits dans le monde des tout
petits il ya quatre structures
disponibles selon les âges de quoi
donner de la sécurité pour pouvoir
s'amuser tranquille et je vois quelques
petites choses qui apparemment peuvent
être empruntés voilà par exemple pour
emprunter tout ce qui est ballon et
aussi des cartes comme celui ci par
exemple qu'un casque je peux tester
bien sûr
[Musique]
j'espère que vous aussi vous allez vous
laisser tenter attention les activités
ne seront pas assurées le 3 août et il
n'y a pas que plaisir qui joue le jeu
c'est le cas d'autres communes attrape
par exemple on vous invite à la plage à
la piscine jacquemond quo jusqu'au 14
août avec des semaines à thème du côté
de nos repas direction le café de la
plage deux mois d'activités manuelles
sportives et familiales avec des temps
forts au mois d'août à rambouillet ont
fait durer le plaisir jusqu'au 2
septembre bergerie plage ouvre ses
portes tous les jours à 14 à une plage
de sable une piscine de paille des
tracteurs à pédales des cahiers de
vacances
impossible bien sûr de citer toutes les
communes mais pour profiter pleinement
de votre été rendez vous sur cas ce que
pense qu'il point fr pour moi l'été a
déjà commencé
c'est la fin de ce set it was here merci
de nous avoir suivis et merci aux
équipes de tv soixante dix huit pour
cette année c'était ma dernière émission
j'ai été ravi de partager cette saison
avec vous n'oubliez pas de profiter
entre amis ou en famille et comme le
disait sénèque à tétouan de bien vivre
et son jeu que chaque jour est à lui
seul une vie je vous dis à bientôt et je
vous souhaite un très bel été
m
[Musique]
vous